hi my name is Tom nas and I'm the
Maryland State Geography Bee champion
I'm going to show you a few things about
myself my hometown of Rockville in my
home state of Maryland hi i'm here at
the Antietam National Battlefield in
Sharpsburg Maryland which is about an
hour west of my hometown of rock the
reason I'm here is because his burrow
really triggered my interest in
geography and I'm specially interested
in Civil War II and where the main
bathroom civil war as else also the
bloodiest day in American history I'm in
the Maryland management at the mt of
National Battlefield this moderate or
honors the soldiers brought with both
Confederacy in union or native the
marrow people often ask me how I
memorized all the geographical and
historical fact i say i love to learn
about themselves easy for me people i
also say people were asking that
question is not just about learning the
city's rivers capitals and countries
it's about connecting them to human
events i'm standing in the sunken Road
at Antietam National Battlefield this
town is also known as a bloody lane the
battle event on the bun September 17th
1862 the battle occurred and
twenty-three thousand Americans lost
their lives over the course of the day
it is the bloodiest day in American
history to the north the spiral in terms
of battle of antietam to the south is
bad will be forever be known as a battle
of her
I remember the old Montgomery County
Courthouse in my hometown of Rockville
Maryland Brownsville is attorney sealed
montgomery county is also the sister
city of member of germany and this year
celebrating its 150th birthday eyelid i
love to go to the all the restaurants in
rockmelt go to the local movie theater
and to a local ice cream shop home
difference in the neighboring town of
the best does where my school which is
home or what it is located my school
just really sure when powering the
entire state of maryland this makes me
very proud of my school hi I'm an
Annapolis Annapolis is a capital of
Maryland and the Maryland State Capitol
building is behind me Annapolis was the
capital of the United States from 1783
to 1784 Congress ratified the treaty of
paris with end of the revolutionary war
and that building up there it is the
maryland state capitol building is the
oldest state capitol building just still
in legislative use all Marylanders love
Annapolis think it's a great city I
think I could I think I have a fact that
i can stop national geographic lyst
gerardus what was the currency of the
United States from the end of the
revolution to the ratification of the
Constitution do you know it if you don't
know it here it is there was none under
the Articles of Confederation all the
states were printing different
currencies hi I'm in Annapolis again and
horrible Harper's behind me and just be
phased out there Annapolis is also on
the u.s. Naval Academy and it's also one
of the most beautiful harbour towns in
America thank you for watching my video
on
you